unrestrained by typical TV standards
Netflix is able to produce and
distribute a nearly unlimited amount of
original content at a spectacular rate
including an array of high quality
offerings such as stranger things
andum breakable kimmy schmitt but that
doesn't mean it hasn't put out a few
duds over the years since it can be
pretty difficult to keep up with
everything Netflix puts out these days
we've rounded up some of the best stuff
the company has introduced since the
beginning of 2018 along with a few
you're really better off avoiding Best
lost in space
TV sci-fi was very much in its infancy
when the original lost in space debuted
in the 1960s so the show never looked
particularly good
despite its ambitious premise yes spare
us your ridiculous remarks you
insensitive idiot
Netflix redeemed the lost in space name
by rebooting it as an epic drama full of
multiflex level special effects the
characters have been refined too driven
by the talents of a top-notch cast in
this reboot Molly Parker takes the lead
as an aerospace engineer attempting to
lead her family to a colony at Alpha
Centauri the villain has also been
gender flips with the iconic dr. Smith
now played to a hilt by indie movie
queen parker posey I go where you go
not that I don't trust you worst the
Cloverfield paradox the third
installment in the Cloverfield anthology
finds a team of scientists played by
Daniel Bruhl Elizabeth de vikke and
Chris O'Dowd stranded on a remote Space
Station attempting to tap a new source
of energy instead they mishandle a
particle accelerator wind up in an
alternate dimension and send a familiar
monster hurtling down to earth
basically think a Lia only more
convoluted and led by a plot too thin to
justify its many twists and turns best
wild wild country this six-part
documentary series is an intricate and
almost unbelievable story of crime
corruption exploitation spirituality and
human darkness it tells the story of a
commune by followers of the Indian
spiritual guru Bhagwan Shree Rajneesh in
1981 and the grim events which took
place after things began to spiral out
of control the series tells this bizarre
and frightening tale in a slow and
precise manner with plenty of archival
footage and interviews with former
followers of Rajneesh many of whom were
close knit members of a group known for
its mass stockpiling of weapons heavy
reliance on arson and penchant for
poisoning salad bars it's not to be
missed
worst mute mute had everything going for
it the cast included a host of stars
like Justin Theroux Paul Rudd and
Alexander Skarsgard it was co-written
and directed by Duncan Jones the mind
behind modern-day sci-fi classics like
moon and source code even the premise a
mute bartender searching for his missing
love and a futuristic Berlin seemed like
it was full of potential
but when mute finally hit Netflix in
2018 bands were left disappointed
Rosie Fletcher of Digital Spy summarized
the movie best saying the whole film is
populated by people you don't believe or
care at all about behaving in ways that
don't make sense again state
cheap-looking sci-fi by numbers
background
best a futile and stupid gesture on its
surface it's the story at the beginning
of the National Lampoon the premiere
humor magazine of the 1970s and early
80s but a futile and stupid gesture is
also the life story of his co-founder
Doug Kenney tempting but he flatly saw
the light the Lampoon was an incredibly
influential brand staffed by personnel
who went on to produce a range of iconic
comedies including Caddyshack and Animal
House the cast is bursting with comedy
stars all paying tribute to their heroes
Joel McHale portrays his community
co-star Chevy Chase while Seth Green
pops up as Christopher Guest Will Forte
is a revelation here too turning in an
oscar-worthy performance as Kenny a
gifted comic genius who suffers at the
whims of his own demons even as he goes
on to change the world
yeah so these actors don't look exactly
like the real people but come on you
think I look like Will Forte when I was
27 do you think Will Forte is 27
worst game over man if you weren't a fan
of the long-running Comedy Central
sitcom workaholics you're probably not
going to find much to love here game
over man takes everything that was
thrown into that show and dials it up to
11 jokes about genitalia tons of them
romanticized 80s action movie violence
endless irreverent profanity-laden
banter between the three leads you
betcha
the movies thin plot is essentially a
dull rehash of diehard which isn't
enough to mask the fact that onder's
home Blake Anderson and Adam Devine are
still portraying the exact same
character types they played on
workaholics great if you love that show
not so great if you didn't altered
carbon based on the 2002 novel by
Richard K Morgan altered carbon is set
in a far-flung future in which
scientists can upload a person's
memories onto an implantable disc it's
essentially a highly stylized crime
story filled to the brim with
body-switching
sci-fi tech and murder 5 most frequently
murdered
allows me being in AI makes that less
likely no although both tremendously
violent and sexually charged altered
urban also explores identity on a
philosophical level that sci-fi hasn't
matched since the matrix worst the week
of the week of places the now fifty year
old Adam Sandler and the doofus dad
phase of his career while giving us a
new Sandler to go along with silly
Sandler and serious actor Sandler boring
Sandler Isaac likes Jimmy Lee and he's
aware that Jimmy Lin no longer plays for
the New York Knicks it's a very nice
shirt $7.00 at motels seriously furry
little happens in this movie it takes
place during the week of his daughter's
wedding to the son of a surgeon played
probably unsurprisingly by Chris Rock
Sandler gets into some slapstick messes
up preparations for the big day and
fringes half convincingly at the price
tag the whole way through to his credit
the title is appropriate the week of
really does feel like it takes that long
to watch best queer I in the 2000's
Queer Eye for the straight guy launched
the metrosexual movement five homosexual
guys stereotypically renowned for their
excellent tastes in fashion interior
design culture grooming and cuisine
provided makeovers for slovenly
heterosexual men stereotypically
renowned to be woefully incompetent in
the matters of taste I love a good
designer meat while the original queer I
was plenty of fun Netflix's reboot is
something altogether more vital during a
time of political and cultural division
queer eye makes for a series of moving
tales of personal connection acceptance
and healing and the fact that the
regular cast are so downright
charismatic and inspiring doesn't
exactly hurt things either we all got to
come together in a way where we can
understand each other worst a little
help with Carol Burnett's
in an unfortunate turn Carol Burnett's
first regular TV series in decades
turned out to be a forced awkward mashup
of dr. Phil and kids say the darndest
things in each episode Burnett's along
with criminally misused co-host Russell
Peters takes questions about life and
love and all things related from a
studio audience
the
Burnett's usually joined by a celebrity
guests attempts to scramble an answer
together before throwing the query over
to a panel of cute and precocious kids
who quite clearly have no idea what
they're talking about maybe just like
don't have a friend it's not exactly
riveting stuff
[Music]